and joining us now national institutes
of health director dr francis collins
doctor welcome back to fox news sunday
good morning to you sir uh what do we
need to know about the omicron variant
is it more contagious will it lead to
more severe disease your thoughts sir
well those are the right questions trace
and this is early enough that it's hard
to be sure we know the answers and
that's what a lot of us are spending our
time on over the last three days i think
i've been on zoom calls and phone calls
pretty much continuously we do know that
this is a variant that has a lot of
mutations like 50 of them and more than
30 of those in the spike protein which
is the part of the virus that attaches
to your human cells if you get infected
that is of new record in terms of the
number of mutations it does make you
worry therefore that it's a sufficiently
different virus that it might not
respond as well to protection from the
vaccines but we don't know that we can
certainly see that in south africa and a
few neighboring countries in south part
of africa this does seem to be spreading
quite quite rapidly so the inference
would be there that it's particularly
contagious we don't know about its
severity uh trying to collect that data
as quickly as possible
yeah and i'm interested when you talk
about spike proteins it tends to confuse
people when you say various mutations
and spike proteins specifically sir what
do you mean by that
so remember the picture of this virus
that it has these
spikes on its surface which are made up
of protein that's the part of the virus
that has to find a receptor on your cell
to get inside so there's sort of a lock
and a key there
and this one is apparently able to still
do that it's infecting people but the
shape of that protein is different
because of these 30 plus mutations so
that it looks a little different so if
you've raised antibodies against that
from previously being infected or from
being vaccinated the question is will
those antibodies still stick to this
version of the spike protein or will it
evade that protection we need to find
that out to be honest though that's
going to take two three weeks in both
laboratory and field studies to figure
out the answer and that's what all of us
as scientists want to know
and very quickly because i know you say
you don't really know much about this
variant but when you have these doctors
in the south african medical association
including one who actually spotted this
variant
down in south africa and he says you
know the symptoms tend to be mild is it
too early to make that declaration
i think it's too early trace i think the
initial cases were mostly young people
who tend to have mild infections anyway
we need more data there before we could
say confidently that this is not a
severe version of the virus but we
should find that out in the next couple
of weeks so dr collins let's move on now
the president has put a travel ban in
eight south african countries let's put
those on the screen here's the
vaccination rates of those countries you
can see they go all the way up to 27 in
lesotho and then all the way down to 3.2
percent in malawi which is
extraordinarily low the former biden
advisor dr zeke emanuel said the
following and i'm quoting here
restricting travel is going to slow it's
coming not stop it from coming the fact
that it's coming here is inevitable the
environment in which it comes may not be
inevitable we can alter the environment
and if it's just a case of trying to
slow it down dr collins why not put in
place more travel bans because the
people in south africa some of the
government officials there feel like
they're being singled out feel like this
is a little bit discriminatory against
them
well i think it is a difficult decision
trace and this is just the best advice
of the public health experts and you'll
notice other countries like the uk and
the eu are doing the same
keep in mind of course that everybody
who's a foreign traveler coming to the
u.s has to have a test three days in
advance if you're vaccinated one day in
advance if you're unvaccinated so we are
screening travelers from everywhere but
given the current circumstance out of an
abundance of caution seeing that this is
the most serious new variant that we've
seen in several months it made sense for
uh at least for a temporary measure
we're not going to say this is going to
be there for a long time
to block travel from those countries
where we know omicron is already
spreading
yeah we we talked about the vaccination
rates in some of these south african
countries i want to put up the
vaccination rates and booster rates from
this country doctor because it's it's
kind of a fascinating look here 59.1
percent vaccination that's fully
vaccinated 19.1
of boosters and the question is will the
vaccines need to be modified for for
omicron i mean and if they do need to be
modified
why would people get the booster
tomorrow when they might have to get a
brand new booster in 30 days in two
months
well trace i'm glad we're talking about
this for americans listening to this
right now this is an action you can take
if you're not vaccinated yet or if you
haven't gotten your booster it's clear
that in all the previous examples of
variants the vaccines have worked to
provide protection and the boosters have
provided especially strong protection
against things like delta given that
history we expect that most likely the
current vaccines will be sufficient to
provide protection and especially the
boosters will give that additional layer
of protection because there's something
about the booster that causes your
immune system to really expand its
capacity against all kinds of different
spike proteins even ones it hasn't seen
before so please americans if you're one
of those folks who are sort of waiting
to see this would be a great time to
sign up get your booster or if you
haven't been vaccinated already get
started omicron is one more reason to do
this now if we need a new vaccine
designed specifically against omicron
pfizer and modern are already in the
process of designing that but that's
going to be at least three months or so
to come into being if we have to do it
all of us hope we don't need to do that
so you think it will be modified but for
now for the time being the vaccines we
have are working just fine i want to put
up the four states and their vaccination
rates because that really kind of gives
us an idea here of where we're going you
see michigan 54
vaccination rate a new case rate of 59
percent main kind of the same thing very
high vaccination rate high new cases new
york 68 22. you look at the bottom there
dr collins you have florida 61
vaccination rate down in cases you know
it was only a couple of months ago the
media was giving florida an awful hard
time saying that ron desantis policies
were all wrong what's going on here why
are some of the states with with some of
the most severe lockdowns and mandates
doing poorly and states like florida
that have virtually no mandates doing
quite well
well it all comes down to who is
actually
getting the disease and especially who's
getting sick enough to be in the
hospital or to die keep in mind
getting us a mild case of the illness
certainly happens as breakthroughs from
the vaccinated folks although boosters
really help prevent that but if you're
talking about who's in the hospital and
who's dying those are still the
unvaccinated people and there are lots
of those in all the states you just
mentioned if there's a lesson here it's
come on america we have missed the
chance to be at a much higher level of
vaccination across the country that
would put us in a stronger position for
all those reasons of misinformation that
people have heard we've not done what we
should have done to protect ourselves if
if omicron is one more wake-up call then
let's wake up and come on america you
can do this these vaccines are safe
they're effective people have been using
them for more than a year 200 million
people plus have gotten injected these
are something you want for yourself your
family your community yeah dr collins
i've got about a minute left here uh you
talk a lot about these anti-viral pills
merck and pfizer and some of them say
look these are game changers these pills
are game changers do you worry that when
they come out with these new pills and
they are as effective as what we're
being told that it will lessen people's
you know need or or you know hurry to
get this vaccine
it does worry me trace although it would
not be a rational conclusion because
these are pills that you would take if
you're shown to be infected you don't
want to be infected
take the analogy do you want to wear
your seatbelt or just forget that and
count on the emergency room to patch up
your broken bones i think the seat
belt's a better deal the vaccines are
your seatbelt use them if for some
reason you still get sick it'll be great
to have these antivirals i am tickled to
see them emerging malnupiravir the merc
drug will be debated on tuesday the
pfizer drug pax levitt is not far behind
it's great that we're going to have
something like that but that is not the
whole answer prevention is better than
treatment yeah it is a bit of good news
dr francis collins thank you for joining
us sir we appreciate it
glad to be with you trace